[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with Kate Andrews economics
correspondent at The Spectator and
Jonathan list journalist and commentator
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now well The Mirror
Has a warning from unions that the
conservatives are risking lives in
failing to avert upcoming strikes by NHS
staff
this is not our battle Metro leads with
the head of the Armed Forces warning
that soldiers are not spare capacity to
use during strikes
the express says nursing unions are
willing to compromise over their pay
demands
the eye leads with a warning from
paramedics that a delay in 999 call
response times is costing lives
the telegraph says a senior NHS Source
has warned that elderly patients who are
fit to be sent home are likely to be
stuck in hospital over Christmas because
of the strikes
whilst The Daily Mail leads with anger
at pundit Gary Neville for his
comparison of a striking British workers
to migrant workers in Qatar
borderforce strikes threaten misery for
millions of passengers arriving at UK
airports that's a report in the times
in the hand of God is the headline on
the sun with the paper focusing on
Lionel Messi's team's win at the World
Cup
covid's rapid spread in China is causing
medicine shortages and widespread
illness that's on the front of the ft
the guardian leads with a report that
workers who made genes for Tesco in
Thailand report being trapped in
effective forced labor
and the daily Stars front page has a
story about dogs overheating if they
sleep under the covers
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Kate Andrews economics correspondent at
The Spectator and Jonathan list
journalist and commentator welcome to
you both let's start with the Daily
Mirror and this story accusations that
the government are cold-hearted and we
hear from the the unions um I believe
it's uh
the unite General Secretary Sharon
Graham representative she's saying that
it's Steve Barkley who's holding the
country to Ransom and not the unions
Kate
yes that's the quote from the United
General Secretary the implication being
that as these Strokes go on within the
Health Service it's the Tory government
that is putting patient lives at risk
not the strikers of course amongst this
pay dispute we also have a political
dispute going on with 7.2 million people
on the wait list on NHS English England
alone with tens of thousands of
appointments thought to be canceled
because of this first round of nurses
strike it's very hard to make the case
that nobody's life is being put at risk
there's certainly a serious
inconvenience up to a danger for
patients in terms of what's taking place
and both the strikers the workers going
on strike and the government are
desperate to say that it's the other
side's fault
um so this is certainly the Union's
perspective that it's the Tory
government's fault of course we do have
accounts elsewhere we had in the
Observer uh today that Steve Barkley is
thinking about a one-off payment that
might feature in some kind of settlement
rather than escalate didn't pay for the
long term and then of course the Daily
Express day for tomorrow's papers
suggesting that the nurses are willing
to compromise at the moment they are
asking for a pay raise that is close to
double what inflation is in the UK now
they want a 19 pay raise so
um I think the the implication here and
the reports are that they're moving
slightly closer to some kind of dialogue
which is positive for everybody involved
including the patients but there is a
real political game playing out with
these strikes as well as questions over
actual pay and and that's what the
mirrors headline is reflecting for
tomorrow yes if Jonathan the implication
is that if the health secretary Steve
Barkley were to hold talks on pay that
that could avert tomorrow's War count
well it seems completely extraordinary
that we have our nurses paramedics going
on strike and their actual Health
secretary not being front and center
obviously the government says that
there's an independent pay body which uh
sets uh the rates of wages but this is a
national crisis affecting the NHS and of
course the many other areas of natural
life as well with with other striking
workers
um and you'd think that the government
would be you know all hands on deck
trying to stop this rather than just
sort of sitting back and watching the
disaster unfold a disaster let's not
forget as you just alluded to which
could be costing
um people's lives and so it's the least
um we could expect is it Steve Barkley
would be sort of getting his hands dirty
in this and I think that look it's not
for me to say what figures uh
negotiators should be making or
accepting but certainly I think that we
have to have a conversation about the
way in which we value and different
workers in this country and we have to
remember only two years ago when we were
standing outside our doors every
Thursday evening to applaud nurses but
we didn't actually take the pains to
appreciate them in monetary terms and
that is a fundamental error that we've
made in this country
to the Metro where we hear about
criticisms of contingency plans for
dealing with the strikes the head of
Britain's arms forces has warned that
his Personnel not spare capacity to use
during strikes because uh we've got the
the line that soldiers are going to be
driving ambulances to um avert any well
potential disasters Kate
this is a really important part of these
strikes but also a broader narrative
around Britain's several crises that I
think often goes overlooked and we have
the head of the British Armed Forces
coming out making a major statement
saying we are not spare capacity and
that is of course linked to the fact
that about 600 military personnel are
expected to be driving ambulances in the
wake of these strikes
um but this is not specific just to
these strikes and it's not specific just
to covid I mean it was it was a regular
feature in in developed countries across
the world that when we were at the
height of military personnel were
stepping and it was happening in the U.S
it was happening in the UK that's that's
not so surprising but Britain hasn't
been able to escape the state of
emergency really military personnel were
driving ambulances up in Scotland coming
out of the summer because the ambulance
service there was already struggling to
to make good
um on its job and we have the government
now saying that the military is going to
play a greater role in the small boats
crisis now you might accept that there
is some role to be played but I think
the statement is actually rather
extraordinary in the sense that you have
the head of the British Armed Forces
saying You must remember that we are not
the backstop that is not our design yes
we are there for a domestic emergency
but essentially we're not there to pick
up the pieces when we have failed public
policy and in a myriad of areas um and I
don't think this will just be directed
to the government it will be directed at
at other staff too and particularly at
departments you know if there's a
question of pay look at those Department
budgets where is the money going I mean
the NHS has a record amount of money
funneling into it and that extra 13
billion pounds promised to catch up the
Health Service part of that was supposed
to go to nurses pay where is that money
there are a lot of questions to be asked
the politicians of the workers and
specifically of department heads at the
moment uh sort of get their act together
and stop using the military uh as as the
last resort and Jonathan it's quite
serious what Admiral Sir Tony radican is
saying because he's saying that it would
be perilous to rely on troops and it
could hamper the Army's otherwise work
we're busy and we're doing lots of
things on behalf of the nation we've got
to focus on our primary role
I mean ultimately the Army is
responsibility of the British government
the British government has the ultimate
say in where the Army uh you know is is
is is
sent you know and so if there are
strikes uh deployed as what I was
looking for so there are strikes and
obviously the army that is the time for
the Army to step in the I remember in
2002 uh when the fire uh fire brigades I
went on strike and the Army was sent out
in green goddesses it's not an everyday
occurrence the danger that we have in
this country is that we're going to get
more and more strikes in the next few
months and so the military will have a
more day-to-day role in taking over
um the jobs of the people who are
striking and that is an important issue
to be discussed because obviously people
in the military might complain uh that
they don't have the right to go on
strike for example uh the police don't
have the right to go on strike and so
there are there is a risk that working
people are kind of turned against each
other by which I would obviously wish to
avoid and most people would wish to
avoid but the fundamental issue is the
people are striking for a reason they're
striking because they're desperate
because we have the title squeeze on
wages and living conditions in living
memory because people haven't been
valued because conditions are failing
because they've been failed by
successive governments and uh we
obviously have massive inflation and
people are being given real terms pay
cuts and so
um there is a reason that people are
going on strike they're not doing it for
their own Amusement they're not doing it
deliberately it's deliberately to
inconvenience people and so in that
scenario the government obviously has a
dual responsibility of trying to avert
those strikes trying to resolve the
problems but also to ensure a sound of
cervix if that involves using the
military then Soviet uh just quickly
we've only got less than a minute case I
just wanted to look at this exclusive in
the eye they've got a paramedic who's
actually saying that response times 999
call response times that are costing
lives now
yes we don't have the full details on
the front page but it looks like a
paramedics diary um is is being reported
in the eye talking about these huge
delays that are risking patient lives
and actually over at The Spectator on
our data Hub which you can look at for
free we've been tracking ambulance
waiting times for quite some time now
um and category two which is considered
emergency uh the average wait time is 48
minutes I mean that is clearly
unacceptable so what the eye is
reporting is you know very important
story something that's been going on for
some time and this backup in the Health
Service post covid is just becoming
increasingly dangerous and you have
these poor paramedics who are in a very
difficult position where they're waiting
outside of hospitals they can't get to
the next patient it's a very important
story and really worrying numbers around
it yes it is boring indeeda Kate and
Jonathan thank you very much for the
moment we are going to take a break
coming up this story on the front page
of the Sun in the hand of God picturing
Lionel Messi holding the World Cup
trophy a lot stay with us for more
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview store with me Kate Andrews
economics correspondent at The Spectator
and Jonathan list journalist and
commentator welcome back to both of you
let's take a look at this story on the
front page of the guardian and this is
about Burmese workers who produce genes
for Tesco in Thailand a report
suggesting that they've been trapped
into forced labor working 99 hour weeks
for illegal low pay Kate
yeah a really horrifying uh
investigation uh exclusive from the
guardian which finds that these uh
Burmese workers uh were essentially
slaves in this Factory where they were
forced to work 99 plus hour weeks uh
where they were working for a little to
no pay
um and clearly in many cases against
their will
um Tesco is suggesting that uh these
products were not sold in the UK but the
guardian at least knows that some of
these products have English labels in
them which suggests that they were sold
outside of Thailand and it could be one
of the first lawsuits brought against a
UK company for a treatment of workers
outside of the UK
um of that foreign labor Supply
um so it could set a precedent but
obviously
um it's uh before we even get to that
it's really just a horrifying content
about what these workers were put
through and also a reminder
um you know we're about to celebrate
such an exciting end to the World Cup
and it really was and I you know I I I
watch it I hope everybody else did too
but you know it is a reminder when
you're dealing with these regimes like
in Qatar where we know workers were held
against their will um to help build the
stadiums had their passports taken away
and the rest of it that you know this
stuff is really Rife and it does get
back to us
um you know in countries like the UK
very quickly yeah and Jonathan when you
read the detail it does sound horrific
workers said they had to work through
the night for 24 hours at least once a
month to fulfill large orders
yeah it's absolutely horrifying as Kate
was saying and really interesting as
well
um not just
um that accompanies being held
responsible for a factory uh you know
for the conditions uh in a foreign
Factory but also that it can be held
responsible
um for a supply chains in a factory and
that it doesn't own and also when the
garments aren't necessarily being sold
in this country that's really important
that so this is about Tesco uh to the
products that are being sold in Thailand
although as Kate was saying labels in
English suggests that some of those were
being imported to the UK but even if um
this was purely about Tesco's business
in Thailand the profits are being
funneled back into the UK and it's vital
the British company should be held
responsible for everything that gets
sold under their banner across the world
and that they shouldn't be allowed to
get away with things just because those
those products aren't necessarily coming
to the UK or because they're outside the
direct ownership of those companies in
the foreign Supply chains okay I'm going
to give you the the last minute and on
the World Cup as you mentioned
previously we go to the Ft the winning
team
oh it's the sun we're going to show
let's see that's a more triumphant
picture in the handle
don't give me the full minute I bet
Jonathan knows a lot more about football
tonight
spectator but it was a wonderful uh
final I'm really really exciting and uh
the fantastic news for Lionel Messi is
that he he got to he got to be a part of
this and it was thought that he might
end up retiring not taking part in
Argentina
um re-winning this cup
um and after the career he's had I think
everybody regardless of who they support
feels like he deserves it
um so I mean it was just absolutely
fantastic I was sad that it wasn't
England I was watching but last time I
was on this paper review you know I was
already preparing to be to be let down
and oh yes what we got to watch was
fantastic there you go you used more
than a minute thank you very much okay
um